- [Instructor] We have this diagram here,
party divisions of the
United States Congress.
And what this helps us visualize
is which parties controlled
the various houses of Congress
as well as which party was in
control of the White House.
So for example, during Lyndon
Johnson's administration,
he was a Democrat, that's
why this colored in in blue,
and then we see in this light blue color,
the Senate leaned towards the Democrats,
and the House in this dark blue color
leaned towards the Democrats as well.
But then when you get to Richard Nixon,
you have one party, the Republicans,
controlling the White House,
while the other party, the
Democrats, controlled Congress.
And so this situation right over here
is known as a divided,
divided government.
And as we look down this diagram,
we see that it is not that unusual.
Gerald Ford had a divided government.
Ronald Reagan had a
somewhat divided government
where the House significantly
leaned towards the Democrats,
although the Senate started to lean
a little bit towards the Republicans.
But then if we go further down in time,
we see more and more divided governments.
So if we go all the way
down to at least the present
when this video was created,
we see that George H. W. Bush
faced a divided government.
He was a Republican.
You had the House and the Senate
lean towards the Democrats.
Bill Clinton, at the
beginning it wasn't divided,
but most of his administration,
he had a divided government.
George W. Bush had a divided government
near the end of his administration.
And Obama dealt with a divided government
during the second 1/2 of his first term,
and his second term.
One question is why does it matter
if you have a divided government
like we had, let's say, in this
time period right over here?
Well, one negative of it that
some people will often cite
is that you might have some
form of extreme partisanship.
And partisanship is just a word
that says that the
various political actors
will think more about their party
and their political ideology
than maybe what is in their
best interest for the people.
Or they would try do things in
order to get political points
as opposed to just good governance.
And one byproduct of partisanship
would be a phenomenon known as gridlock.
You might've heard the
word gridlock before
when it comes to traffic.
Gridlock is when there's
just so much traffic
that nothing is moving, that
people just can't get around.
And it essentially means the same thing
in a political context.
If you have a divided government,
and one party isn't allowing,
if everything that the Congress
passes the president vetoes,
or if everything that
the president wants to do
the Congress doesn't
wanna work along with him,
well, then nothing might happen,
and you might get to a gridlock situation.
And for a lot of people,
that's a significant negative.
But there are some viewpoints
that maybe a divided
government isn't as bad
as it sometimes looks.
Some people would argue that
you don't want the government
always doing exactly what they want
when you have a non-divided government.
In fact, if you have a divided government,
they'll only do things that
really, really, really,
really matter where there is
more of a broad consensus.
There's also this view
from Mitch McConnell,
who's the current leader of the US Senate,
that it's actually
easier to get things done
during a divided government.
This is a part of an article
from the New York Times written in 2011.
It says, "Divided government
is the perfect time
"to do big things, the perfect time,"
Mr. McConnell said in a recent session
with New York Times reporters and editors.
He cited three fairly recent examples
of major legislative bargains
that were struck with one
party in the White House
and another running
things on Capitol Hill,
the 1983 overhaul of Social Security
negotiated between President Ronald Reagan
and Speaker Tip O'Neill.
Ronald Reagan was, of course, Republican,
and Speaker of the House,
Tip O'Neill, was a Democrat.
Sweeping 1986 tax law changes.
Once again, under Ronald Reagan.
And the welfare reform package of 1996
negotiated between President Bill Clinton
and Congressional Republicans.
Clinton, of course, was a Democrat.
"None of those things in my view
"would have occurred
in unified government,"
Mr. McConnell said, referring
to control of Congress
and the White House by one party.
"The differences are always big,
"but if you can bridge the differences,
"then you can survive."
The beauty of divided government,
very few people say that,
the beauty (laughs) of divided government,
in the eyes of Mr. McConnell
is that it provides both parties
with near bulletproof political cover
since neither can attack the other
after legislation is passed,
while it also gives both parties
the ability to take political credit.
So I'll leave you there.
I want you to think about it.
Do you agree with Senator McConnell
that divided government can
actually be a good thing?
Or do you think this notion
of divided government
and partisanship does lead to gridlock,
and for the most part it is a bad thing?
And then we could also think
about our system of government,
because our system of
government definitely allows
for things like gridlock to occur,
while many other systems
like a parliamentary system,
you always have the majority
or a ruling coalition party
also in charge of the executive,
so you're not likely to
have this type of gridlock.
So think about it.
Which system do you like?
And is a divided government
a good or a bad thing?